بعيدا عن صحه القتال تشتد حرب موازيه بين
قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
حربون لا تقل ضراوه يتراشق فيها الطرفان
البيانات والبلاغات مستخدمين صورا واشرطه
فيديو الحديث هنا عن حرب المعلومات فمنذ
بدايه الاشتباكات في السودان لم تتوقف حمى
الاخبار والبيانات عن اجتياح وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي اخر فصول هذه الحرب
الصراع الدائر حول مبنى القصر الجمهوري
فبينما اكد مستشار قوات الدعم السريع يوسف
عزت سيطره عناصر الدعم على القصر الجمهوري
لم يتاخر الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني في
نفي ما وصفه ادعاءات قوات الدعم السريع
نحن نسيطر على القصر الجمهوري نحن نسيطر
على كل المغاره
المتواجده على طول كل الوزارات نؤكد انه
لاصحه اطلاقا
باستيلاء او سيطره مديشيا الدعم السريع
المتمرده على اي من مقرات القياده العامه
ولا على قصر الضيافه ولا على القطر
الجمهوري هذه التعذيب فصل اخر من الحرب
الاعلاميه دار حول مبنى التلفزيون فطرفان
اعلنا معنا السيطره على مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون في ام درمان الجيش السوداني
اكد استعاده السيطره على المبنى وبث بيانا
وصف فيه قوات الدعم السريع بالميليشيا
لتعود لاحقا قوه دعم السريع وتبث صورا
امام مقر الاذاعه والتلفزيون وتؤكد
سيطرتها بالكامل عليه امام الهيئه القوميه
نحب نطمن الشعب السوداني انه قواتكم قوات
الدعم سريعه الباسله الان مسيطره على
اذاعه القوميه من هنا ام درمان اذاعه
جمهوريه السودان حرب المعلومات امتدت الى
حدود مقر اقامه القائد الاعلى للجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان عناصر من الدعم السريع
نشرت مقاطع فيديو اكدت فيها اقتحام منزل
البرهان قبل ان ينفي مصدر في الجيش
السوداني ما تم نشره معتبرا ان الخبر مضلل
وغير حقيقي من بين اهم الادوات المستخدمه
في حرب المعلومات هذه وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي التي تعرج بالكثير من الاخبار
الداعمه لروايه طرف على حساب اخر وان كانت
هذه الحرب النفسيه الموازيه لا تزهق
ارواحا الى ان تاثيرها قد يكون اكبر على
مجريات الاحداث وسام الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات